hello YouTube I'm Dave Rubin this is the
Rubin report I've got whitney mixter
Brian Noland David Begg now and because
this is youtube and we've got to get to
it quick in the immortal words of my
hero Optimus Prime let's roll all right
so Hillary Clinton she she came out of
sorts people thought she was been down
with the homos for a long time but she
made it official she released the video
with the HRC backing same-sex marriage
but don't take my word for it let's take
a look
LGBT Americans are our colleagues our
teachers our soldiers our friends our
loved ones and they are full and equal
citizens and deserve the rights of
citizenship that includes marriage
that's why I support marriage for
lesbian and gay couples I support it
personally and as a matter of policy and
law embedded in a broader effort to
advance equality and opportunity for
LGBT Americans and all Americans now I'm
not quite sure why Hillary was speaking
so slowly but the message of what she
said we can all get down with I think
Whitney Hillary is down with gays what
do you think I mean and I'm down with
Hillary you know I've always been a huge
Hillary supporter I think it's important
to a support fellow community I mean I
know in all seriousness I love Hillary I
think she's the hardest working woman in
politics I think I really do and you
know I kind of I love what she had to
say I really do but I feel like later on
in her in the video she kind of takes
this approach like come on in the water
is fine merit about marriage you know
like she's like yeah trust me if you
want to get married it'd be my guess
so you think perhaps she was she was
leading a little bit of what her
marriage might I know obviously she
supports gay marriage and I love that
she took a stance on it but you know I I
think that I feel like it kind of
translated later on where she was like
yeah it's been really awesome so if you
want to get married - it's really fun
please join onboard Brian do you think
she was a little late to the party on
this it feels like she's been on board
the whole time but everything all late
to the party at some point you know like
I mean her husband was the same thing
you know like he is now like I love gay
people and be right you know and we're
about to strike down absolutely
incredible Bill Clinton is just like
right I mean everywhere I go you really
go bill um no but yeah I think that they
all kind of do that though where they
all kind of play that card and then when
it's cool like you said the water's fine
I'll just dive in and say yeah I love
gay people gay people are great yeah
David does this mean that she is
officially running in 2016 is that the
sign yeah I think it's inevitable but
look it was the biggest node of the day
I mean really it would have been a
surprise if she came out and said I
don't like the gays yeah it was it was
not a surprise I think it's interesting
that bill did it before she did I mean
he is the Thunder stealer he really is
she's inevitable for 2016 I think
everybody assumes that nothing that she
said was a big surprise today it was
like ya know finally were you guys
surprised that the Republicans didn't
give a rebuttal on the speech they know
better they know better there's not a
Republican in this country who's going
to give a rebuttal to coming out I was
just kidding but you took me seriously I
appreciate that daddy's in New York
cried and prayed for years now like it's
no surprise that she finally comes out
and makes us dancing yeah for that
picture of her staring at Christina
Aguilera's chest that picture is on her
Facebook are you guys David I'll start
with you are you amazed at how quickly
gay rights have changed I mean they
every stat and figure they show you on
gay rights everything's flipped from ten
years ago I mean 58 percent I think they
said this week now backs
gay marriage it's incredible how fast
it's progressed I didn't think it would
come so soon in the mainstream but you
know what ask Rob Portman there is
nothing like having a child who is gay
to change your mind
and you know what get it look regardless
of how I may feel about gay rights I'm
I'm a bit understanding of even the
biggest homo hair and I'm willing to
give them the benefit of the doubt but
all you have to do is put in front of
them a gay loved one and they change
like this it's not matter who they are
Rob Portman or a farmer in Florida yeah
so speaking of Rob Portman so for those
who don't know so Rob Portman the
senator his son came out I guess a
couple years ago to him and he just
announced he's now the first Republican
senator who's on the record backing gay
marriage do you think there's a chance
that because of these numbers that the
Republicans will actually have a pro-gay
marriage candidate in 2016 that's like
the rumor right now is there any chance
or they're still no but you know what
the movement that is progressing I think
in the Republican Party is there's so
many Republicans you know people
Republicans that I know that yeah like
they're so over the social issues
ruining that party you know with gay
marriage and religious issues and
everything and there's people who are
actually Republicans would in the purest
sense and they're I think there's to be
more of an uprising of those people who
are I think pro-pro yeah can we agree
though that it would be a win even if
the Republicans were to come out and say
hey listen we don't have a gay candidate
but we're okay with you guys being gay I
mean even that in the sense might be a
win looked at the study found out today
58% of Americans yeah are cool with gay
marriage yeah first time in history okay
it's gonna happen with the Republicans I
want to see a straight marriage start
crumbling divorce rate you know among
straight couples for years now so I
think that is be as miserable as the
straights that I guess we can end this
topic with this so now by my numbers I
see top five gay icons I'm going be
Arthur Betty White rue mcclanahan still
Getty alert Hillary as number five did
any of you disagree with that would you
like to throw anyone else
I agree would be you know definitely
definitely definitely alright well thank
you for being a friend let's move on to
the second topic CPAC now we're gonna
really change topics here because CPAC
the conservative political action
committee also known as the cantina
scene from Star Wars the circus of odd
characters that they bring out there
they were going on it was going on for a
couple days at the Gaylord hotel which
really you can't make this stuff up and
instead of bringing guys like Chris
Christie moderates in the party they
double down on clowns like Donald Trump
and Ann Coulter let's listen to a little
of sweet Anne's musings thank you some
of you now due to the turmoil in North
Korea are regularly scheduled speaker
ambassador Dennis Rodman will not be
here so I'm I'm filling in I'm Ann
Coulter the author of nine massive New
York Times bestsellers boy the sequester
is really ruined everything hasn't it
their little kids can't go on White
House tours Muslim Brotherhood has been
deprived of 250 million
oh no that's safe sorry that's fine even
CPAC had to cut back on his speakers
this year by about three hundred pounds
Ann Coulter should teach stand-up comedy
is not she wickedly brilliant lordy
Lordy
okay so to start here why is it that the
Republicans pundits are actually more
ridiculous than their candidates who
often are quite ridiculous Brian I pose
that to you to start Coulter cuz it's
like I think she's kind of like that
racist relative everybody has it always
makes racist and offensive comments but
also you know and I think she kind of
represents that for that party like oh
she can say those crazy things and well
laugh and it's okay because she's her
yeah you know and I think it's why it
appeals so it gives them a little
familiarity to graduate with right yeah
and I think it would be one thing if she
was very Pro certain things but I think
she says her are so mean I mean like you
have to have a sense of humor about
yourself and I think we all need to
lighten up in many contexts but she's
not she's saying offensive things about
people who she is adamantly against and
that's the problem we need to get big
and Coulter I mean you know what the
funny thing is like now you look at CPAC
and you know they have Metallica as
enter entering songs they have hype men
essentially I feel like CPAC has become
like the WWE of like political around
like it's really ridiculous I mean Ann
Coulter no she's like this praying
mantis of politician or in the political
world you know I just she's like
beautiful and sexy and like a kind of
like you want to hit her kind of way and
like I just picture her ripping the
heads off of men that she sleeps with
after well she does look like the alien
from Independence Day isn't she very
long and like she's gonna read your mind
and then crush you yeah David what does
this say about the state of the party
that they're pundits are more over the
top you know they bring it in Trump and
yet Chris Christie doesn't get invited
what does that say look here's the thing
I think I mean the round of applause
that she got in front of the
Conservatives was kind of wimpy and weak
manure a Democrat you want Ann Coulter
exactly where she is because Ann Coulter
talks to a base but it's not a very big
base
and so I think you know as much as she
offend you know I met her at church one
time in West Hollywood where the gays
hang out the gay as you said there's
something slightly sexy and sultry and
kind of like I'd be down to have a beer
with you or a cocktail about Ann Coulter
regardless of the hate she may spew
there's something laughable about her
this is very bizarre no but at the end
the day though like I could never like
even in a day she's against Who I am as
a person yeah screw you like nothing to
do that I don't understand I know there
is a lot of gay men are like oh my god
she's fabulous in it up you like
seriously
sorry I mean though you say that I think
it's so stupid I think how could you be
friends or be someone who's so who makes
fun of you and says really offensive
things about you all the time
woman anti-gay anti really everything
that matters in my life I mean no I but
what you're saying you understand it at
some level there's a lot of reason or
rationale you can't sit down with her
and have an emotional discussion she'll
rip you to shreds with you know insults
and all that so when you take her for
what she is and when you realize she is
part of an extreme fringe that each year
seems to be kind of squeezed more and
more I mean every time I turn around
it's like her and Sean Hannity yelling
in some colors but people are listening
and you know as a new poll comes out on
more Americans supporting gay marriage
and as Democrats continue to win
elections it will change its eventual
but in the meantime I kind of like her
she makes me laugh and these are so
ridiculous you're scientists it kind of
makes me laugh well ironically she may
be the best comedian that Republic which
is really she should be your Idol she
should be my sidekick I think you have
to go to church in West Hollywood all
you got to do st. Victor's Church in
West Hollywood she sits in the
second-to-last people in the back of the
church and Coulter if you find a funny
Jew hunting you down at church that will
be me and
I'd love to have you on the show all
right let's move on we've gone from
Democrats to Republicans and now let's
talk about the devil who apparently is
our President Barack Obama if you're not
watching or if you haven't heard of the
Bible it's this very long very preachy
book and they've now put it into a
miniseries on the History Channel and
people are freaking because they think
the guy playing the devil looks like the
president let's look at the picture and
see and we can discuss all right so
there it is
I don't know which is which is that the
president on the left or the right the
devil this is a lot to think about
David what are you guys are you can't
tell me that doesn't look like Barack
Obama there is some makeup artist who
was doing that who is like oh this time
we're gonna make yeah here we go he's
played the double before it's not his
first time I don't think they did this
intentionally but I'm sorry it's all
people were talking about today Barack
Obama is the double yeah his skin tone
actually doesn't look like that I mean
they did change his skin tone and you
know there's there's some facial
structure there so all right one
conspiracy theory yes yes he's played
the devil before but you actually made a
concerted effort to make this man look
like Barack Obama like he actually
doesn't look like that in real life so
you know I I mean absolutely I would go
ahead and say that right that guy looks
like Barack Obama and the Emperor from
Star Wars had a baby yes okay now we
have two conspiracy theories Brian they
believe that the History Channel is in
on this what do you think let me tell ya
I think I actually had some hippy
friends of mine I'm a man of the people
and I know you know hippies very days
you know and they said the same thing to
me like a couple of years ago how the
Bible says that you know a dark figure
will will take over the world or
something like that and he was like oh
there's a there's a conspiracy that he
is AK President Obama s and I was like
that's weird
absolutely don't know if it's yes being
that you know they say a dark figure
will take over and and Mark Burnett is
the producer he's married to Roma Downey
I have to say I had did a little
something I would have gone much more
like this
taking over I would have done something
like that I think that that would that
would have been a much better you know
this is a little bit report firstly I
just saw it as soon as I saw that I was
like but why why not go Della Reese you
know why not cast Della Reese it would
have saved a lot of you know absolutely
well it comes as no surprise probably to
any of you that the History Channel is
claiming that no this was not
intentional they released a statement
which i think is kind of priceless
History Channel has the highest respect
for President Obama the series was
produced with an international and
diverse cast of respected actors it's
unfortunate that anyone made this false
connection histories the Bible is meant
to enlighten people on it's rich stories
and deep history well I guess you can
why would a PR depart maybe I can see
I'm convinced there was a conversation
that went on before this episode area
where they were like no people are gonna
say this I don't think they're surprised
I think they were ready for it what was
funny was that Bek glenn beck's the one
who tweeted after the show aired boy
this bears a striking servant they're
the one that first walked it out yeah
and then Beck today tweeted oh guys you
know give it a rest media lay off it's
funny coincidental but haha not and then
Burnett retweeted Beck's tweet well well
one thing that I think is interesting
about this is that if you guys remember
in the beginning of season two of Game
of Thrones one of the heads that they
used on the Spears was george w bush's
head and you know everyone thought it
was hilarious but now it's Obama people
don't think it's as funny is there a
double standard depend on who your guys
like yeah George Bush's heavies on a
steak but come on I mean
if this were George Bush as the devil
everybody would be luck you know they
would there's not a standard especially
I think that's why I get so much media
play because I think in a lot of the
media Obama is sort of a savior yeah and
so bashing him it's like mmm you did
what right you're a TV and film guy do
what do you think about you know the
process that goes involved in all this
like did they just happen to have a bush
head and then you know oh we got one in
storage or is it real calculated
decision we make that happen like I've
discovered like working in like in the
production aspect of everything that
sometimes you know things get missed and
people do things I think with the bush
head thing I think it was like a prop
guy or something wasn't it said I'm
gonna do this and be really funny and
didn't really make an announcement about
it right if I remember correctly I'm not
sure though that's right I think with
something like this they had to have
seen it like going in at that that's
that it looks like him I'm somebody
realized it but what I have a heart
what's always so worried about these
situations is that everyone talks and
things are always leaked nowadays and
I'm surprised no one on this staff is
keeping everyone on the staff is keeping
it a secret because a bunch of people
must have known about this yeah you know
I mean I just want to know how the Bible
is gonna end
how have been wrapped that cliffhanger a
secret is wrong I don't know all right
let's get away from politics for a
little bit let's talk about news and
there's been some interesting studies
really released recently that people are
not watching the local news anymore I
don't know how they're gonna find out
that cat three blocks away from them got
electrocuted or that you know the
neighbor fell off the roof or all that
kind of stuff but basically people are
turning to tune it out thirty one
percent of respondents in this Pew
survey said they've stopped watching
local news altogether and basically
people are only tuning in now for
weather and sports and traffic now David
I want to start with you here cuz you're
you're a news guy do you think this is
just a sign of the times is this just
everyone going to the internet for this
stuff or is it that in local news it's
just absurd you just see you know the
neighbor that got hit by the car there's
just such a non-stop negative situation
attached to local news that people can't
tell let's hit non-stop you know I've
been doing local news
last ten years and what I hate the most
is people go I don't watch the news
because it's so negative
no can we say you can
see no no because you love
the negative you love the gossip and you
love the blood and gore so that's sort
of a pet peeve of mine it is true that
the numbers are shrinking but it is
because we all walked in here with a
phone and we all have a Twitter account
and that's what we're all checking it's
why I left local news after ten years to
go and do something that was on a
digital platform but I will tell you
this when it rains people watch the news
when they are stuck in traffic you know
they that's when local news will never
go away
is it dwindling sure but doesn't matter
if you're in Bangor Maine or Los Angeles
you're gonna watch your local news yeah
so weather traffic sports Brian are you
gonna miss the absurd stories like just
you know just say something outrageous
in everyone post on YouTube no I love
the local news always turn on the early
morning before you know like the Good
Morning America's and the Today Show's
all come on I'm I always turn on except
with LA it's always like a little like
oh and we'll talked about Lindsay
Lohan's latest court appearance yeah
this is on the local news but yeah I do
like the local max you're right Iran has
the bomb but no I I do definitely make
the local news it says I don't know if
it's just a generational thing but it
feels very safe and it feels very you
know you feel very in touch with your
community where do you get your news I
mean well the thing is you're saying
generational and you know I think has
happened as I think that in this
generational shift we've become more
obsessed with pop culture and what's
happening like you said with Lindsay
Lohan as opposed to you know what's
happening on the local government level
or anything like that you know we we are
obsessed with these stories so you know
Us Weekly is is selling out and people
aren't to an answer unless it affects
their beach community well actually what
you're talking about is something that
we've talked about on every episode of
this show this idea that pop culture has
sort of infected everything else we do
to the point that it so II all our news
is wrapped up in pop culture everyone
wants to stop this book how do we do it
what do we actually do besides talking
about
you're not gonna stop and you know why
because people keep tuning into it we
make fun of Lindsay Lohan but I promise
you when you go back and look at those
numbers today when she was in they're
gonna be off the charts for low Hannah
yeah we relate to celebrities we relate
to their drama we relate to them being
late we relate to them recklessly
driving and lying to police we relate to
that okay I haven't lied to parents make
you feel better about your own problems
they're hard to tell as a journalist
it's hard to make you care why a
community in Southern California is is
600,000 in the red and why their city
manager got arrested you guys already
look forward people don't care about
those kinds of stories so when somebody
throws a glitter bomb at Lindsay Lohan
walking in and then she scores she
thinks it's the new designer cocaine all
right I guess it's all about relating
okay and glitter let's move on something
we can all relate to is the endless
supply of healthy foods that are being
thrown our way and Whole Foods is now
taking it to a whole new level they are
going to be building a Whole Foods Spa
in Austin Texas you're gonna be able to
go there for days and get all your fancy
food and your kin wah and your give me a
fancy food somebody you're healthy
asparagus that was a good one yeah and
you're gonna get massages and detox and
the whole thing so what I want to bring
to you guys is how important is the food
culture to you because I know for me
it's like if I go to Trader Joe's I feel
like I've somehow bettered myself then
go into the regular store but how
important is just the food and the
process of getting food and all that to
you I mean it's incredibly important you
know I I to feel healthier and better
when I go to Whole Foods and Trader
Joe's you know I feel like I'm making a
difference for my body and self however
I must say I don't know if I'd want to
attend a spa that is Whole Foods ran
like I've heard of like farm-to-table
eating but this seems like a farm to
toilet eating like I should just have a
direct - of going in my mouth
my ass and it's like no I kind of like
to keep my massages and like my you know
asparagus separate I don't know I and
also what I don't understand is this
concept that you know they've been doing
these classes and things like that and
seminars and they've actually been
failing miserably so I don't understand
how they've actually said we are going
to take this failing model and we are
going to charge a lot of money for it I
know it's been free so far but we're
actually gonna charge first of all I
can't even get through the damn parking
lot in Los Angeles cuz they're so busy
how are you gonna get through a resort
in Austin Texas that's gonna be another
nightmare I mean look I I you know
sometimes I go to Whole Foods to eat and
sometimes I go to look it's like some of
the creatures walking around in there or
as foreign as the food on the you know I
think it's cool but I mean it's like I
don't know would you guys I don't know
that it's cool like I mean I here
actually have a class they stick a tube
in your mouth
it's a cleansing no I think it's awesome
I think I would love to go to I love
that kind of stuff though so I mean
that's me personally and I know I think
I think in LA I think a lot of health
oriented people would do that but I
think they want to gear it towards more
obese people I'm assuming yes I think so
when I was reading the article I kept
thinking are they gearing this to help
the obese people slim down but I feel
like the obese people they know what
they're doing to themselves you know
what I mean everyone knows what you're
putting it in your body so I think this
is just going to be the ultra healthy
just getting ultra healthy herb although
is it just me or did the ultra healthy
never look that good
when you go to like the the vegan
section of there of the supermarket they
always look like they need a piece of
meat don't they look green you want to
feed these we freedom I agree
everyone needs a steak I agree the
skinny people are the ones that need a
burger yeah alright well we'll end this
one on this question if I was going on a
vacation personally I want to go to a
beach I want to get wasted maybe smoke a
little bit a bit of what we're gonna
talk about in the next story you know I
don't need to be getting healthier and I
don't need to be getting healthier on my
vacations does this idea so I know this
idea doesn't appeal to this healthier on
a vacation I don't know it totally
appeals to me I actually like you know
going on it I like to call it there's a
difference there's vacations and then
there's retreats like if I'm going on a
retreat I like to come back feeling
better
about myself vacation I like to just
wallow on my own regret you know but but
really no I think I'd be interested in
checking it out you know it can't hurt
and I think I'll come back with a
cleaner Colin healthy vacation or bus
man I'm all about it
I mean literally I like to usually go
get wasted and on the beach whatever
like that
David healthy vacation or wasted madness
healthy but I'd want to drink and eat
and you know be sloppy while I was there
fair enough all right guys I want to
remind you by the way my shirts my pants
my shoes my underwear the whole thing is
brought to you by bonobos comm you guys
can enter code TRR to zero and get 20%
off your first purchase of bonobos and
that brings us to our final topic this
week which I completely forgot because
it's weed it's about weed people me
ganja dope
wow that was wild they say it affects
your short-term memory it is quite
possible and I think we just saw
evidence of it so I love this another
Republican we're gonna combine
Republicans and weed into one thing
another one an anti weed guy and guess
what he did he's smoking weed Steve Katz
up in up in New York and so there's a
couple different ways we can go here but
let's start with this or is any
politician not a hypocrite before we get
to the hardcore weed stuff is anyone
that's telling you not to do anything in
your private life not a hypocrite in
their own life Brian first yes no of
course not I mean when I read this story
I was like of course this happened you
know it's it's not it's not any kind of
shocker you know I mean it's it's it's
like one of those things where I
remember my parents telling me one time
that they smoked weed at the neighbor
when I was growing up and I was like
really you know my parents but then
again it's probably not that shocking
and really think about it you know
everyone smoked weed at some point in
their life well I'm sure your parents
will be happy that this is now out there
on the internet everyone knows oh gosh
mr. and mrs. Noland out in I believe
they're in California Oh fart all right
we'd where do you fall on the weed thing
because everybody look it to me it's
going to it's gonna help the economy you
can start taxing it let's just talk
about the broader weed topic look
working in local news I've been
convinced by some people who I respect
that it's still an issue and it's an
issue they think that requires it to
continue being outlawed so you know I
don't raise ins you know look the
Sacramento County Sheriff who I have a
whole lot of respect for here in
California will tell you ten different
reasons why he has seen from arrest to
parents what it does to households what
it does to children he doesn't think
it's a good idea I'm not saying I'm
right but it's something I don't use and
it's something I don't you know I mean
we'll see what happens isn't inevitable
maybe what I love about these types of
stories is it makes politicians like
this guy seem human because they go out
there and they're like you know you
we're better and and in a way I'm better
than you
and then he's running off to smoke does
well and the funny thing about what this
guy was the bill that he helped veto was
to legal legalize medicinal marijuana
not even recreational like he was
smoking weed to get high to have fun
exactly and he didn't want people to
help themselves medically now I want to
ask the dreadlock member of the panel
now you know I understand what you're
saying you know but at the same time I
think a there's bigger fish to fry
in politics and in the world and you
know I definitely think that as you were
saying about alcohol alcohol is
definitely more damaging not only to the
human body but also to you know just
families yeah exactly I've never really
had someone you know OD on weed or get
you know they have that weed and breaks
into a bank I think or yeah you've never
seen somebody just completely lose their
because they're they smoke the ball
you know and and it's just like I do
appreciate I do think that you know it
does humanize these politicians because
you know people take these stances and
they're so strict on it but it's like
you know yeah it's you're obviously you
have hypocritical things it's just
be so staunch is basically what I'm
saying like don't be so damn staunch if
you know you're doing it yourself like
if you're gonna be strict on something
just choose something that you know
you're not gonna go home and light up
when you get back
it isn't this another one of these
bizarre cases where the Republicans who
like to say that they're all for freedom
and individual liberty and you can do
what you want in your house and it
should have nothing to do with the
government but they want to get all up
in women's wombs and they want to
regulate how much weed you smoke or let
that you smoke it at all etcetera
etcetera so it seems like a a bit of
it's not even something ain't jiving
with me about that it's a well I mean
they do they do still want to regulate
absolutely as much as they want to
remove tons of government they
absolutely want to regulate what I think
that they associate marijuana with a
liberal mindset and you know I think
that that's what they want to kind of
regulate over well yeah thanks they're
tracking my anus you know well note my
glaucoma has been acting up so I think
I'm gonna take the panelists out to the
parking lot and we'll see what's what I
thank you guys for watching and this has
been the Reuben report we'll see you
next week